metropolitan police in the last few
moments have released these images
of 10 men that they want to speak to in
connection with
disruption and the violence that we saw
here at wembley last sunday now
before i go any further it is just worth
saying that the police saying they want
to speak to these men they are not
directly accusing them of anything
but they are saying that they want to
identify their men they're asking for
the public's health
um help and they want people who know
who they are to come forward because
they believe these men
have questions that they can answer now
we saw pockets of disruption
all across the country last sunday but i
think the scenes that we saw here at
wembley
were by far the most shocking here on
wembley way there were tens of
thousands of fans packed in many of them
of course had just come to enjoy the
atmosphere they hadn't come to make
trouble
but there were people who had came here
clearly to make trouble they'd been
drinking since early in the morning
many of them resorting to violence and
then of course those
unbelievable scenes that we saw of many
fans
streaming into the stadium who didn't
have tickets
breaking down the barriers breaking past
security
getting into the stadium possibly at the
expense of people who did have tickets
now
in relation to that the police have said
that they have made two arrests
they've arrested two 18 year old men on
suspicion of
stealing items which may have helped
people get into the stadium
without tickets now it's not clear what
those items are but they're please
saying that they have
reviewed many many hours of cctv footage
of body cam footage and anybody who is
responsible for any violence disruption
they will hold to account now the uk
policing football unit have said that
in the 24 hours surrounding the final
they arrested 264 people
and of course as well as as well as the
scenes that we saw here on wembley wayne
and other areas there were also
the torrent of racist abuse that we saw
online now
relating to that police say that they
have made five arrests in connection
with that people who allegedly made
social media posts
but particularly with the the security
beach at wembley there are
longer term implications that this may
have
because of course the uk and ireland
have got that bid for the world cup in
2030
there are fears that the scenes at
wembley put that in jeopardy so i think
the government
the fa and the police will be very clear
and want to send the message
that the scenes that we saw at wembley
are being dealt with and will not happen
again